there was a massive tent city popping up
in texas border patrol agents releasing
more than 1500 migrants
who tested positive for covet into
mcallen in just the past week alone
bill malugen back at his post at the
border la jolla texas today and
what you learned about this bill good
morning
well bill just to give you an idea of
how bad it's getting down here the city
of mcallen has declared a local disaster
and they are not happy with the federal
government take a look at this video we
shot
yesterday from the ground and from our
drone this is an emergency tent compound
they literally built
overnight essentially what it does is it
houses illegal immigrants who have been
released by border patrol the city says
the federal government
has just been dumping illegal immigrants
in downtown mcallen and they can't
handle it anymore you saw those busloads
of them being dropped off at the
catholic charity well the charity can
only take so many people and the city
says
there's a risk of hundreds of migrants
being left out on the streets of mcallen
so they had to build this compound to
help house some of these people and
migrants started showing up yesterday
the city blasted the federal government
in a statement staying
saying in part quote the city intends to
demand relief from the federal
government for the alarming number of
migrants that are being released
into the city of mcallen as these
immigrants are released the federal
government does not test them for
covid19 so who does test them it's a
third party provider
and we got some shocking stats from the
city here for you take a look at this
graphic
city mcallen says the federal government
has released seven thousand coveted
positive migrants into their city just
since february
more than fifteen hundred of which were
in the last week alone we talked to some
local residents who are not happy
to see this tent compound pop up in the
middle of their city take a listen
there's probably not enough planes or
buses to get all these people out of
here
and this is probably an overflow from
the rest of the center
we get that too but again
there probably could have been a better
better uh
location than sticking it right smack in
the middle of mcallen
there were some protesters at that
compound yesterday and we've just
learned the city has decided to move it
to county property
it's being set up at ansel dewis park
now in a different location
one last thing to point out horrible
crash that happened about an hour north
of us in brooks county
yesterday a possible suspected human
smuggling incident a van was carrying
30 illegal immigrants the driver veered
off the road crashed into a utility pole
10 people are dead 20 are injured
and again this is being investigated as
a possible human smuggling incident
tragic situation there we'll send it
back to you it's just awful bill thank
you for that things are upside down
again bill millusion thanks and